are you ready to take your digital
marketing career to the next level
crafting a compelling digital marketing
resume is your ticket to Landing that
dream job in the dynamic world of online
marketing your resume is your digital
billboard showcasing your skills
experience and achievements to potential
Employers in a world where attention is
scarce and competition is fierce your
resume needs to stand out like a viral
social media post let's dive into the
art of creating digital marketing resume
that not not only captures attention but
also compels employers to hit the apply
button so now let's have a look at what
we are covering in this video so we'll
start with looking at examples of resume
professional experience education skills
certifications then we will cover some
useful tips to create an awesome resume
and at last we will understand how to
make a digital marketing resume for
freshers and experienced but before we
begin make sure to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and press press the Bell
icon to never miss an update from Simply
learn so let's start with the first step
which is looking for examples of resume
so before you start making your digital
marketing resume it's good idea to look
at some examples of a well-crafted ones
in the same field this can help you
understand how to format your resume
what kind of languages to use and what
content is most effective for digital
marketing jobs keep an eye out for
resumes that have a strong personal
brand clear communication and relevant
work by deciding out of these examples
you'll get better idea what works well
and be better prepared to create a
resume that catches the attention of
potential Employers in the competitive
world of digital marketing reviewing
examples of digital marketing resume can
provide valuable insights into the
industry's best practices look for
resumes that effectively showcase the
candidates unique value proposition such
as their expertise in SEO social media
management content creation or data
analysis all right once you're done with
this now the next step would be
professional experience so when
describing your work history Spotlight
your achievements and influence you had
in your past positions make your impact
clear by using action words and
measurable outcomes to Showcase your
contributions rather than just outlining
job responsibilities emphasize
accomplishments like boosting website
traffic enhancing conversion rates or
successfully executing marketing
campaigns this approach provides a
dynamic view of your capabilities and
highlights the tangible results of your
efforts by focusing on these
achievements you not only paint a vivid
picture of your skills but also
demonstrates your ability to drive
positive outcomes in the professional
realm so if you are interested in
advancing your career consider Purdue
University postgraduate program in
digital marketing this comprehensive
program offers certification as digital
marketer through live Interactive
Learning dive deep into fundamental and
Advanced Digital Market marketing
strategies utilizing Hardware business
school publishing cases and student
simulations and Hands-On participation
in 20 plus projects access the full
spectrum of digital marketing tools with
chat gbt and AI tools complemented by 35
Plus dedicated resources all right so
this was about the professional
experience now if we'll talk about the
next step which is education so
education in the education section of
your resume showcase your academic
qualification
relevant coursework and any honors or
Awards you have received if your degrees
aligns with the field like marketing or
communication emphasize it this
highlights your foundational knowledge
don't forget to mention any specific
courses or workshops you have completed
especially if they include valuable
certifications in digital marketing this
signals to employers that you actively
pursued additional skills and knowledge
in the ever evolving digital landscape
remember this section is not just about
degrees it's about snapshot of your
educational journey and commitment to
staying current in your field so make it
shine with your achievements and
relevant educational experiences all
right so this was about education now
coming to the next step which is skills
so skills in the skills section of your
digital marketing resume highlight your
expertise in essential tools and
platforms this includes a range of
skills such as Google analytics where
you demonstrate yourability to analyze
website data SEO proficiency showcases
your knowledge of optimizing content for
search engines ensuring maximum
visibility social media management
skills indicate your capability to
strategize and execute impactful
campaigns across platforms then email
marketing expertise email marketing
expertise emphasizes your ability to
create and manage effective email
campaigns additionally your aptitude for
Content creation highlights your
creative and communication skills it's
crucial to tailor these skills to match
the specific requirements of the job
you're applying for showcasing your
versatility and alignment with the
employes needs by doing so you present a
well-rounded skill set that enhances
your appeal as a digital marketing
professional so this was about the
skills of a digital marketing
professional that you can include in
your resume after that there are
certifications so certifications if you
have learned certifications in digital
marketing like Google ads hubsoft
inbound marketing or Facebook blueprint
make sure to Showcase them in the
special section of your resume
certifications such as these highlight
your dedication to professional growth
and can make you stand out among other
applicants including these qualification
not only proves your expertise in
specific areas of digital marketing but
also signals to employers that you stay
updated with industry standards this can
be crucial factor in setting you apart
and demonstrating your commitment to
ongoing learning in a competitive job
market certification act as a tangible
proof of your skills and can
significantly enhance your chances of
securing that dream digital marketing
position all right so this was about the
certification section of your resume now
coming to the interesting part of this
video which is useful tips to create an
awesome resume so now we will be heading
to the useful tips so crafting a
standout digital marketing resume is
like creating your professional Story
start by tailoring it to the job you
want highlight skills like email
marketing social social media marketing
content marketing and Su expertise that
match the roles requirements imagine
your resum as a visually appealing and
well organized document using a clean
and modern format to Showcase your
creativity to make your impact even
stronger don't forget to add some
numbers quantify your achievements with
Statistics it's like adding a splash of
color to your story if you increase
social media engagement or boosted
website traffic let the numbers do that
talking now here's the Finishing Touch
proof reading just like when you are
sharing a post on social media check
whether your resume for any typos or
errors attention to detail is crucial in
the digital marketing world so there you
have it tailor your story highlight your
digital marketing skills and add some
numbers to impact and polish it off with
a metalicious proof read this way your
resume will stand out in digital
landscape ready to catch the eye of your
future employer so this was about useful
tips to create an awesome resume now
coming to the next very interesting part
which is how to make a digital marketing
resume for freshers and experienced all
right so let's move on to that so when
creating a resume whether you're a
fresher or an experienced professional
it's important to pay attention to the
layout and content a well-crafted resum
can significantly impact your job
prospects for freshers a good resume can
help you stand out despite limited work
experience while for experience
professional it can showcase your skills
and complete lishments effectively when
creating your resume it's important to
include action items and action verbs to
Showcase your skills and accomplishments
effectively for example increase organic
views by 20% reduce bounce rate improve
ranking Etc instead of saying
responsible for managing a team you
could use Le a team which sounds more
active and engaging this applies for
both freshers and experienced
professionals by incorporating action
items and action verbs as well as
highlighting questionable achievements
you can make your resume more Dynamic
and impactful this approach can help you
stand out to potential employers and
increase your chances of securing the
job you desire the layout of your resume
is crucial it should be clean organized
and easy to read use Clear headings and
bullet points to make it visually
appealing for freshers the layout should
emphasize education and any relevant
internships or projects for experienced
professionals the layout should
highlight work experience and key
achievements all right now for both
freshers and experienced professionals
it's important to include your contact
information educational background and
any relevant certification or training
fresher should also include sections on
skills and projects while experienced
professionals should focus on V
experience and accomplishments when it
comes to what to avoid steer a clear
understanding of including irrelevant
personal information such as your h obes
or martial status additionally avoid
using generic one size fits all resume
for every job application tailor your
resume to specific job you're applying
for yes this is very important after
that the order in which you present
information is also important for
freshers it's best to start with your
education followed by any internships or
projects and then skills now for
experienced professional begin with your
work experience followed by the key
achievements and then your education and
skills so these all things you can do in
your resume for an experienced
professionals so crafting your digital
marketing resume is not just about
listing experiences it's about telling a
compelling story of your skills and
achievements tailor your resume to the
specific job you desire showcasing your
expertise in email marketing social
media marketing content marketing and SE
a clean and modern formats adds a touch
of professionalisms making your resume
visually appeal
don't forget to sprinkle in some numbers
quantify your achievements to make a
lasting impact lastly proof read your
resume with metalicious attention to
detail a Flawless document not only
reflects your commitment but also
ensures you make a memorable first
impression in the competitive digital
marketing landscape so all right guys
with that we have come to the end of
this video If you like this video please
give it a thumbs up I hope it really
help you all thanks for watching stay
safe and keep
learning